nous sommes en présence de madame
desbassyns une femme qui a vécu très
longtemps 91 ans ce qui est incroyable
pour cette époque là et dans notre
inconscient collectif madame desbassyns
représente la femme diabolique qui
incarne tout cette période de
l'esclavagé cette douloureuse que nous
avons tous connu et en ce qui me
concerne j'ai voulu représenter une
madame desbassyns avec un peu plus
notamment d'humanité vous voyez que il
ya un chien à ses pieds et ont donc ça
lui apporte une certaine chaleur humaine
et elle est en train de vie et son code
de son code de noir c'est pour montrer
que telle était malgré tout respectueuse
du droit de l'époque et par ailleurs
vous voyez qu'elle lit le code noir
malgré son son âge très avancé sans
lunettes
et c'est une femme qui qui était l'une
des plus grosses fortunes de france
c'est un personnage incontournable en
tout cas du patrimoine historique de
notre île est là elle se retrouve dans
son jardin assis sur un banc de 10 style
de l'époque
c'est une oeuvre qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre d'une scénographie que j'ai
réalisée sur le thème des esclavages du
marronnage il madame desbassyns a tout à
fait sa place et madame dumas s'est
réalisée dans un gros galets que j'ai
trouvé pris sous le pont de la rivière
des pluies
c'est une roche pintade comme on appelle
ici avec des cristaux blancs d'oeuf elle
se bat et ce gars là a été travaillée au
marteau et au burin et puis avec
un peu de polissage à certains endroits